hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the environmental causes of
schizophrenia developmental hazards
social defeat and drug abuse
I am Brenda Kelly Kim of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or submit
your problem to the green Q&A button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker Sir Robin Murray Robin
Murray is a professor of psychiatric
research at the Institute of Psychiatry
and indeed has spent most of his working
life there apart from one year in the
USA fortunately the latter did not do
him too much harm his particular
interest is in understanding the causes
of psychosis and he and his colleagues
have contributed to the understanding
that environmental factors such as
obstetric events heavy cannabis use and
migration increased the risk of
developing schizophrenia like psychosis
he'd also sees people with psychosis at
the South London and Maudsley NHS trust
who have been referred from across the
UK because they have not responded to
treatment locally
he has written numerous articles not all
of them boring and he has the second
most frequently cited psychiatrist
outside the USA he has supervised 52
PhDs and 35 of his students have become
professors he was elected a fellow of
the Royal Society in 2010 and received a
knighthood in 2011 I will now turn it
over to dr. Murray for his presentation
very much so I'm very pleased to talk
with you and I'm going to talk about the
environmental causes of schizophrenia
but of course when we're considering the
environmental causes we have to of
course realizes that genetics anchors
are important we've known that for very
many years but since last year we know
some of the specifics it was a huge
study published in nature of 37,000
cases of schizophrenia and 113,000 a
healthy controls and this showed that
there were a hundred meat loss I
significantly associated with
schizophrenia so this was a fantastic
early important they finding I was at
the conference where this was C
announced and the audience stood up and
cheered because it's the first big
breakthrough in the genetics of
schizophrenia in here you can see my
countrymen and Scotland out in the out
in the street I shouting hurrah hurrah
underneath low sigh for schizophrenia so
this has been this is a big deal and we
know that some of the genes implicated
include HLA and that may be the HLA type
interacts with infective causes that
we've known about in schizophrenia one
of the genes was the DRD to the dopamine
gene and we know what many of us
psychiatrists spend our time they try to
block this receptor with antipsychotics
some glutamate genes which say I are
involved in the control of dopamine and
some neurodevelopmental genes and we've
known for a while that neuro development
is important in a city Nia and from the
environment mental point of view we can
now get a polygenic risk score so that
everyone from a patient to you and I can
have a polygenic risk score done to
assess our liability to schizophrenia
and of course we can then see how that
interacts with environmental factors
so apologies are important in
schizophrenia and now that we know that
more than 100 genes involved this is not
compatible with the idea that
schizophrenia is a discrete condition
it's more compatible with the idea as a
continuum of liability to psychosis so
psychosis is a bit like a hypertension
there's a distribution through the
population most people aren't very they
paranoid or prone to psychotic ideas but
you all know you'll have some friends
who are a bit suspicious a bit paranoid
can get the wrong idea once this goes
past a particular cutoff point we need
to have a some intervention we call this
clinical psychosis and schizophrenia
although there's a lot of fuss about the
exact definition it's really just severe
psychosis so you can think it's like the
distribution of blood pressure a
particular cutoff for hypertension and
another and severe hypertension
it's called malignant hypertension and
schizophrenia is like malignant a
psychologist we also know that copy
number variants are involved in
schizophrenia where there's a deletion
or duplication these are conquered by
10% of cases of autism that also found
in learning disability and epilepsy and
has been the question are they found in
schizophrenia and indeed they are this
is the first study was published in 2008
and been many replications here's the
replication that I was involved in large
recurrent micro deletions as copy number
variants associated with schizophrenia
you can see there was a huge number of
authors I actually was more authors
there was 76 authors only 66
abnormalities and all the patients with
schizophrenia but it got us a paper in
nature you can see me in the middle and
read their eye so it's a great thing to
collaborate with stay geneticists cuz
you you take the blood user then you
send it off and you get them you get a
paper in nature
but the importance of the copy number
variant and skips veneer is that unit it
reinforces the neurodevelopmental
hypothesis for 30 25 years we thought
unit development is involved in
schizophrenia but now that there are
these copy number variants which where
there's a knockout or a deletion or
duplication of anterior developmental
cheats this confirms that there is a
continuum of developmental impairments
from learning disability to autism who
schizophrenia though bipolar disorder is
not associated with neuro developmental
abnormalities so you can think that one
route into schizophrenia is a
developmental one and some children show
subtle motor cognitive and social
deficits compared with their brothers
and sisters they get social anxiety and
depression as they go into their teens
begin to develop quasi psychotic ideas
and cnvs
copy number variants are one cause of
this that the impaired certain yura
developmental a genes also other little
little jeans like BDNF or a disc one
mark Z and s they are also involved in
neuro development and they together they
may impair a new development and put
people on the on the Cascade toward
schizophrenia
this can be compounded by pre and
perinatal events i we know for example
that hypoxia if you have say hypoxia
bursted prolonged labor if you have if
you're born preterm all these factors
increase the risk of psychosis and
there's some some evidence not really
very hard that prenatal inspection may
also increase the risk of skin screen
you probably
individuals have there's a genetic
susceptibility of course many many of us
had difficult births but if you have the
genetic susceptibility and then hypoxia
at birth the two may interact to push
you on this caste
towards schizophrenia so you end up in
your adolescence being a bit odd having
some quasi psychotic ideas suspicious of
your schoolmates but you're not
psychotic
what is it that converts into psychosis
well we know in psychosis there's this
regulation of the dopamine system that
much evidence suggests the final common
pathway to schizophrenia is excessive a
dopamine synthesis and release in the
striatum and in this slide you can see
this try to dopamine neuron producing
too much I don't mean and we
psychiatrists spend our lives trying to
block the blue and postsynaptic
receptors of course it would be more
sensible if we could decrease the
release of dopamine but we can't do that
so we block the receptor now we know
that that occurs when people are acutely
psychotic but what about in the prodrome
before people actually develop the
full-blown syndrome when they're just
wondering whether somebody is speaking
about them wondering if they hear a
voice wondering whether some of these
interfering with their brain does these
such individuals also have increased
dopamine and this is a study by all of
our houses in our department and this is
a PET scan study using fluorodopa to
estimate the uptake and synthesis of
dopamine in blue are the controls in red
are frankly psychotic people and you can
see that that's significantly different
in the middle are people in the prodrome
with this so-called
at-risk mental state of whom about a
quarter will go on to develop psychosis
and you can see that their dopamine
levels are midway between the controls
and the psychotic people here's another
way of looking at it
here are the controls in the beige and
yellowy here are people who do not who
have
I the prodrome have the address mental
state but they do not stand it into
being frankly psychotic when I followed
up and in the red our people who had
baseline when first seen are in the
address mental state but go on to become
psychotic you can see that they already
have the increased striatal dopamine and
this next slide shows that as they go to
want to Frank psychosis so that third
strike of dopamine gradually increase so
it's striatal dopamine that is the
crucial factor in a changing an
individual from a an eccentric odd
adolescent or young adult into a frankly
psychotic one listed this this
regulation of sealians caused by the
excess dopamine so that's the
developmental route into psychosis
partly genetic partly environmental but
we know that drug use can also increase
the risk of schizophrenia with known
that for 50 years 60 years now actually
it that Phillip Colonel Reed wrote a
monograph of a series of people who had
amphetamine psychosis and he looked
exactly like paranoid schizophrenics and
in most cases around 30 min psychosis if
people stopped taking the feta mean then
after a few weeks or a few months the
psychosis goes away but in about 10%
occasions it doesn't belong where you've
abused amphetamine or indeed
methamphetamine because in recent years
that's upset Amin has been a much bigger
problem than amphetamine
methamphetamines psychosis spreading
from the Far East to Australia South
Africa California and then across the
stage that it's quite easy to understand
why this causes psychosis because I'm
feta mean methamphetamine increase I
effectively increase a synaptic dopamine
the more synaptic dopamine you have then
in stratum then the more likely you are
to me psychotic but what about cannabis
I and of course attitudes the cannabis
are changing here you can see an advert
and I think Santa Monica Bridge Beach in
California you can open the Sun you've
got a sore head or you feeling a bit
visible you can go off and see a doctor
and get medical marijuana which will
cure all known diseases or the doctor
will say it will cure it and will charge
a for this prescription and of course I
got some Californian doctors are getting
very rich on this I hear is say Barack
Obama who's struggling to try and this
is of course as push for a picture but
he's struggling to know whether the the
federal government should change its
attitude to marijuana or not so most
people who use marijuana have little
problems just like most people who use
alcohol have no problems and I show a
picture work Obama because the last
three presidents of the US have all they
used say a cannabis marijuana Bill
Clinton your memo said he didn't inhale
I I think a George Bush a pinky used a
marijuana but also a among some other
drugs and Obama in his youth used
marijuana they didn't seem to come to
any harm from me from the cannabis that
there are some people who come to harm
just like with alcohol most people use
it sensibly don't have any problems but
a few people use it excessively and
develop problems and with alcohol its
liver failure and so on with cannabis
the big problem seems to be psychosis
and on the left hand pocket corner you
can see that the now benign cohort
studies that studies of the general
population divided up into those who
smoke cannabis and those who don't smoke
cannabis and then followed up for a
period of years the biggest study is
Swedish study Swedish army study 55
men followed up for 25 years and the
ones who smoked cannabis at baseline
when they were 18 they were three times
more likely to become psychotic and
there's a whole range of studies you can
see right the odds ratio on the
right-hand side of the cohort studies
you can see that all the odds ratio is
increased in every case for those who
are using cannabis that's very unusual
than psychiatric epidemiology for all
the studies to go in the same way so
people said well maybe the people who
are using cannabis are using other drugs
so some of these studies have controlled
for that people are using amphetamine
and so on others said well maybe they're
peculiar people are using cannabis and
so in other studies they excluded
anybody who at baseline appeared to be
abnormal whatever you try whatever
concerns you look at you can maybe
decrease the odds ratio but you can't
get rid of the effect of cannabis so I
think it's generally accepted now that
using cannabis as a modest effect in
increasing the risk of psychosis and of
course it depends on how often you take
the cannabis and as well see the potency
of the cannabis up on the top right hand
corner you can see our particular study
which was carried out in New Zealand in
the pink you can see the risk of
psychosis by by 26 years you've started
using cannabis by 18 years it was one
and a half times so it just increased a
little bit not significant but if you
started using cannabis by 15 even for
four and a half times more likely to
develop psychosis and several other
studies have also shown this that if you
use cannabis when you're 12 13 14 then
your risk of developing psychosis is
considerably greater than if you wait
till you in a in your 20s or later one
of the interesting things that has been
happening to cannabis is it has been
becoming stronger so if you think of
traditional cannabis from
hippy days and in 60s and 70s the
proportion of THC tetrahydrocannabinol
the active ingredient in old-fashioned
cannabis was maybe about three or four
percent but it has slowly increased and
not in all forms this is kind of is
resin which is commonly smoked in Europe
not so much the state and a it stayed
much the same at least in the UK run
about five percent of THC
this is imported herbal cannabis may be
called weed or marijuana Austin and you
can see it's got a bit stronger up to
about nine percent THC but what has
happened a in Europe and mugging a
little bit behind but also in the states
has been a the the engineering really
are the plant and engineering a to
produce much a higher concentration of
THC so now you can get a particular form
of cannabis called sinsemilla
are often called skunk and this has the
THC content of about sixteen to twenty
percent so that's nothing four times
stronger than a traditional
old-fashioned cannabis and this is
associated with a greater risk of
schizophrenia for example this is a
study that we've done in South London
actually martyred the forty it was the
lead a researcher and this looked at all
the patients who came into our local
hospitals with first episode of
psychosis and compared their use of
cannabis with that of the local general
population and we could show that 24
percent of all cases of first episode
psychosis in South London were
attributable to the use of high potency
cannabis that is to see if nobody smoked
high potency cannabis in South London
that'd be one needle nearly one-quarter
fewer cases of cycles now we live in
South London an area where cannabis
consumption is very common so I'm not
seeing that everywhere I
of all cases of Kosovo to the use of
high potency and cannabis but the
villain in other countries people have
made estimations of 15 percent or 12
percent or so so on so anyway it would
be very good if we could persuade people
not to smoke the high potency cannabis
even to go back to a traditional lower
potency cannabis would be a beneficial
so this is this shows why the high
potency cannabis is such a problem this
is the risk of being a psychotic case in
dr. d40 study over on the left you can
see people who've never used cannabis
then people who have used hash or resin
and it almost looks as as hash or resin
is protective but that's not significant
the the decrease there it's when you
start using skunk or high potency
cannabis your risk goes up so if you use
it less than once a week you double your
risk if you use it at weekends you'll
treble your risk if you're using it
every day high potency cannabis I wanted
one or more joints a day your risk goes
up five times this is called skunk in
Europe because of the strong smell of
the of the cannabis so that would
suggest that people won't give up
cannabis totally it might get it for
them to go back to old-fashioned hash or
resin then smoke no canvas it was of
course the case still that only a
minority there was adolescents who use
high potency cannabis will develop
cycles is just like only a minority of
people drink alcohol a headily will
become dependent and and developed with
liver failure
so naturally we'd look to see whether
there's any genetic susceptibility is
that there's an environmental risk
factor interacts with genes or the
environmental risk factor is obviously
cannabis and indeed our been three genes
have been associated with
please risk of psychosis if you dig
cannabis it was a study of categorical
transferees absalom caste was a first
author suggested that if you had the met
met a genotype then your risk was much
higher that has never been properly
replicated but there are two other genes
I which do increase the risk of
psychosis
if you take a cannabis one is the DRD to
the dopamine gene dopamine receptor gene
and another is a KT one which is
involved in the dopamine signaling after
the dopamine receptor so it seems that
these genes are post post the receptors
so genes are making the receptor more
sensitive seem to increase your risk of
going psychotic with say cannabis so
what's the mechanism well we're the
cannabis user a is converted from a calm
a person enjoying their joint aid to
being psychotic for some very
interesting work by Natalie Geneva in
Switzerland has shown if you give THC
the active ingredient of cannabis to
rats
interestingly you don't actually
increase the dopamine and the striatum
in the long term you get a transient
increase and then you get a decrease in
the a dopamine but you seem to get the
post-synaptic hypersensitivity and
that's a bit reminiscent of what I just
told me about the the genes at the genes
a postsynaptically that's infinitely
more vulnerable and so what Natalie says
it's the result of the infinitely of the
synaptic hi puddin
hypo function of the dopamine but
postsynaptic hyperfunction means that
there's a next facilities of dopamine
activity and it's maybe this which
accounts for the psychotic
skycutter genic effects of THC I've
explained this a little more in the next
slide
so this is re showing the protein
synthesis and regular cannabis users
versus non users in the blue earth
controls in the green are the kind of
users and you can see that they manage
to depress their dopamine and levels by
constantly use a bead argan I've shown
the even and such people where they have
low dopamine if you give it unfair to
mean and produce a small increase in
their dopamine levels increase that
would not have any effect in most of us
this could precipitates psychotic
symptoms in these cannabis users and
that is I think because we have this a
super sensitivity and my colleagues and
I encrypt in the paper saying that
chronic cannabis use indices lowest
right or dopamine as do other country
tendencies but also the concurrent
development of post synaptic super
sensitivity so when you take here once
you have the cannabis once you have the
super sensitivity and you're smoking
your joint as well as getting the normal
high you also get the super sensitivity
which gives you the rich cause if we
agree psychosis so as well so that we
showed you the developmental route into
psychosis it is also the a dopamine
dysregulation of simians root now you
have the drug abuse coming down here and
some individuals are particularly
susceptible so there are these two
routes into psychosis the developmental
you route where individuals often have
problems from very early in life and
then there are the drug abusers and
interestingly they are often not well
usually they're not developmentally
appeared at all rather they're often a
very clever very sociable and street
smart the sudden boy at 13 and 14 he's
got lots of friends who knows his way
around he's socially able enough to find
a somebody to give him cannabis and he's
clever enough to get money out of his
parents the convent
to be spared to pay for the kind of
cannabis without then finding out so
these are street smart kids who are
quite different to the
neurodevelopmental the impaired children
but they end up sadly would say the same
psychotic syndrome so there's the the
developmental route there's the drug
route what about social factors now for
most of my life
we academic psychiatrists tended to
discount the effects of social factors
but really in the last ten years we've
realized that social factors are indeed
important this is an epidemiological
study or first episode psychosis in
three and English cities all individuals
living in three defined areas who
presented to psychiatric services with
their first psychotic service in saikhan
excuse me first psychotic episode so we
could estimate the incidence of
psychosis and indeed of schizophrenia in
these three different cities and
psychosis and schizophrenia were much
commoner in central London twice as high
as in nothing and in Bristol and
actually higher in these cities than in
the country there's lots of studies
showing that the incidence of
schizophrenia is higher in the city we
used to think this is caused by social
drift of people drifting very into the
city it's not it's mostly caused by a
inner city breeding their own people
with psychosis and interestingly in
Europe at least is the northern cities
if you look at the cities in Italy and
Spain their rates of psychologists are
much lower why well drug abuse and Ave
amphetamines and of high potency
cannabis is higher and Holland and in
Britain than in the Mediterranean
countries but maybe there's also
something about the social experience
and the cities and so we've looked at
social factors
and in this study we showed that the
risk of schizophrenia is increased by
migration lots of studies have shown
migrants are in increased risk of
psychosis and the schizophrenia and it's
quite easy to understand this if you go
to a foreign culture you don't quite
understand it I you're more likely to
think people are trying to to be against
you or cook you for you know for any of
us who go to a a client a foreign
Airport you actually you get a taxi how
many minutes is it before you begin
thinking if this Texas taxi taxi driver
I think I'm a fool is go guide the
circles in order to charge me too much
we're all more prone to a paranoid
thinking in a country where we're not so
familiar with the culture but got
particularly black migrants so people
from Africa the Caribbean migrating into
Europe have much higher rates probably
because of the unfamiliarity but also
because of the discrimination if you
repeatedly discriminated against do you
think people are against you
well maybe eventually you learn that
they're against you even when they're
not so you can be almost taught a type
of paranoia so migration increases the
risk shell through the adversity losing
your parent and neglect particularly
abuse physical or sexual abuse we all
know know that this increases the risk
of most psychiatric disorders including
psychosis and severe psychosis
schizophrenia and we also know that
acute stress from adverse life events
increases the risk so it's common for
example that in the six months prior to
somebody having their first psychotic
episode the first schizophrenic episode
that they will have had some calamity
happening to them and usually an
intrusive event rather than a loss
depression is associated more with loss
but being beaten up or being burgled
being bullied having some event which
threatened you is more associated with
risk of psychosis but if as I stated
earlier the final common pathway to
psychosis is dopamine this regulation
then can social factors cause this mean
it presumably we have a unitary
hypothesis underlying the psychotic
symptoms the salience hypothesis then as
social factors involved we must a surely
a can be influencing the person as well
and in the last few years we've begun to
realize that this is the case so for
example studied by Mizrahi and our
colleagues in a Toronto they took a 12
ultra high risks subjects these people
in the prodrome and 10 drugs naive
schizophrenic patients and they stressed
them using the Montreal stress test this
is a nasty test actually you get people
to do a series of arithmetic 8a a tests
while in the scanner and even though
they get some of the tests right you
tell them the guys they got it wrong and
you also tell them you're doing the
worst in the group and afterwards we're
going to publish the results and you're
going to be really at the bottom so
you're letting everybody down and
everybody's going to take that really
really badly we can't be very clever
hey so you're really stressed by by a
being told this and no matter how hard
you try you still took told that your
results are wrong so when you do this
you get dopamine release but you get
more dopamine release by 6.9% in
high-risk credible something's and by 11
percent in the schizophrenic subjects
here you can see this the controls on
the left the high risk in the middle and
you can see in the green the slight
increase in their dopamine release and
in the schizophrenic people
you can see the greater dopamine release
so stresses are so associated with
dopamine released and it particularly
seems to be the case in in those people
who are either in the prodrome are
actively psychotic here is a studying by
colleague as Egerton has just completed
it's in submission at present and this
was taking adults who were not psychotic
but some of them had had a nasty
childhood and some hadn't so for example
in the graph on the left
it's a divided by those who had either
had severe sexual or physical abuse or
hadn't if we just look at the left graph
you can see I on the Left those who
didn't experience any abuse in childhood
and those on the right who did
experience the adversity in childhood
and you can see that the dopamine
release they fall following a stress
they say the same stress test was say
greater in those who had suffered the
abuse on the right-hand side of the
slide this is those these healthy adults
divided into those who had not had any
changes in their family arrangements on
the left and on the right those who had
fewer more family arrangements and so
you know step several divorces in these
separations in the family and again you
can see that those who experienced the
adversity of more family arrangements
they responded by more dopamine release
so the point I'm trying to make here is
that stress causes dopamine release but
particularly in those who have suffered
as adversity as a child so it does seem
that social factors like stress or
childhood stress can indeed release a
dopamine and as we discussed earlier eye
drugs like I'm setting in also release
dopamine
as cannabis has this more complicated a
effect on the door on the rattled
opening system but all of the stress
like on excuse me all of the risk
factors from schizophrenia seem to
impact on stifled dopamine so back to my
slide that you've seen already the
developmental routes into psychosis the
drug abuse trade routes into psychosis
and here the social adversity through
into psychosis this seems to operate a
via the HPA axis so you get increased
cortisol you also get increased dopamine
so there are at least three routes and
the developmental route the drug abuse
route and the social adversity route so
you may think well this is all very
theoretical i what are the implications
for clinical psychiatrists like myself
Oliver house and I wrote article in The
Lancet last year really trying to
integrate the biology with what we know
about social and developmental and
cognitive models of kids vineya so the
model really would be that of
individuals who have a biologically
sensitized dopamine system they may have
inherited a different variant of the DRD
- or the akt1 or some other AI gene
Wednesday makes the dopamine system
sensitive sensitive or they may have had
some environmental factors in childhood
the coaches sensitized their dopamine
system or they may have been taking
drugs which sensitize their immune
system then they have an acute social
stress that presents a say they say that
they're assaulted or some other
adversity happens to them this will
result in them producing more dopamine
release we know when that happens you
get aberrant processing of stimuli
dopamine makes you attend
two things all of us we attend to ping
the release dopamine that when you're
running on too much dopamine then you
begin to think all sorts of
insignificant things are significant but
run the orange so I'm sure I those of
you who are listening given no idea how
many red cars you've seen today but if
you're running on too much titled
dopamine you notice all these red cars
you take fire all these red cars
following the great red big danger are
they all are they all collaborating to
somehow follow me is there a conspiracy
going on - somehow harm me so you
release more dopamine in response to the
stress that's causing the aberrant and
processing of stimuli and particularly
if you've had a bad childhood that means
you're more suspicious of other people
we tend to react and a paranoid way then
you're going to be more likely to
develop a paranoid interpretation of
these these phenomena that you begin to
see the you begin to think you didn't
get a voice or you think seem very
strange or all around you and you wonder
whether people are looking at you
strangely you develop a paranoid
interpretation you develop psychosis
then what happens when you develop
psychosis well by this time you're sure
that other people write to get you and
of course this means that say you feel
much more stressed you think people are
like to go to get you then of course you
have an argument with your neighbors
they shout at you
eventually the police are called and
they at least admitted what would then
happen would be that the police would
call a psychiatrist the social worker so
tightest would come along by this time
the individual was barricaded in their
house they're saying you can you're not
going to get me I know you're out to get
to get me a psychiatrist comes along
persuades the and says the patient say
well you you're not well you have to
come into hospital and you see not know
I'm certainly not coming in I know that
you're in league with say my parents and
and these people down the road who are
out to get me
and of course you're more stressed they
release more dopamine you get more
paranoid interpretations you go
psychotic by this plan you're shouting
and maybe you're waving at a knife out
your door they to stop people getting
you the police coming and overpower you
take to the hospital and where you're
injected and of course by this time your
dopamine release is as high as possible
so in a sense you get into a circular
pattern of evermore increasing stress
and evermore increasing dopamine release
of course what we do in the clinic is we
try and give a dopamine blocker to block
the dopamine release to block the
salience and therefore decrease the
paranoid interpretation and then
gradually as people recover we try and
remove the factors of the causing the
psychosocial stress which can get people
to talk about the difficulties that they
had in their childhood that makes them
more inclined to a they interpret things
in a paranoid wing and so we try and
break into this aberrant cycle so with
any luck I think we can do it and my
view is that schizophrenia is not a
deteriorating illness and with proper
treatment we shall expect majority of
people to improve and some to recover so
just a finish at that point and thank
you all for listening thank you very
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit your questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can our first question for dr. Murray
is how to convince someone who is in
denial of their illness I'm squished
answer 19 30 seconds well I should say
it is very difficult but I think the
most important thing is to persuade the
patient we're on their site hi I
recently shared for two years as kids
vineyard commissioned in the UK and with
many people came and said I hated the
psychiatric services nobody paid any
attention to me I didn't think my
medication I was a terrible mess and
then I met a psychiatrist who seemed to
listen to me and understood me and
seemed to care about me and it was that
empathy that seemed to make the
difference so my view is the caring and
the kindness of the patients that will
help to get people to develop some
insight and they won't necessarily
develop it immediately it will take a
number of meetings but I think one can
be the most brilliant
psychopharmacologist and manipulate all
the very efficient antipsychotics it's
not as effective as a good kind
scientist patiently for talking
recitations okay our next question can
hypnotherapy be useful for schizophrenia
after a person is stabilized after
taking psych hight psychiatric medicines
if yes then how to proceed in
hypnotherapy can age regression be used
I have never met a patient who is
benefiting a patient with psychosis who
is benefits from from hypnotherapy I've
met patients with anxiety or depression
are other non psychotic conditions who's
benefited from a hypnotherapy but I
haven't met people who've benefited from
hypnotherapy I have met several patients
who've got worse within the therapy I
could think of one young student who
actually had the onset of her psychosis
after she was hypnotized on stage so I
think people with psychosis have very
fragile
of things and be pushed into a strange
and estranged consciousness I think can
actually be be detrimental for people
with psychosis so I'm not against a
psychosocial treatments and in
psychosocial treatment are very
important but I don't think he'll
pathetically is sensible for people with
psychosis thank you
our next question regarding the stress
induced release of striatal da wouldn't
this normally result in a
desensitization well I think we don't
know enough about say about this and I
think obviously most of us when we're
stressed we don't go sonic otic and yet
we are releasing dopamine in response to
the stress of course it depends how much
dopamine were releasing but I suspect we
don't know this yet but I suspect that
the difference between those of us who
get stressed and get depressed or
anxious and those of us who just clash
and then go psychotic is that really not
only release the dopamine but we have
some vulnerability at the receptor so I
think it'll be that it'll turn out we
don't I hope we shall notice very soon
with all the developments of genetics
but I think it would be postsynaptic a
vulnerability that makes one individual
more likely to develop the psychosis
when the rest of us can cook but the
dopamine increased a stress or the
stress released
thank you our next question why do other
agents that facilitate mesolimbic
dopamine activity for example nicotine
cocaine alcohol etcetera not result in
psychosis or increased risk for
schizophrenia well it's a very
interesting question and I would agreed
alcohol does not seem to increase the
risk of
skids keenya I obviously could cause
lots of other troubles I cocaine
I think cocaine use a does increase the
risk there's a study from a man called
Karen in California followed up all the
people in California health system I had
been to the accident and emergency unit
with either methamphetamine use or
cocaine use over the next ten years the
best unsettling users were ten times
more Alex become psychotic cook users
were about four times more like it's
become psychotic so I think cocaine is
accepted as being a cause of psychosis
no and I don't think it's in any way as
say as adversely or risky as say as
methamphetamine perhaps because people
don't take it and they don't get just so
dependent the question regarding
cigarettes if you would ask me this a
three or four years ago I would have
said there is no evidence that a
cigarette smoking and nicotine is
associated with increased risk of
psychosis but I don't believe us any
longer and we have just done a
meta-analysis of all a studies looking
at smoking and it's vineya now it's
common knowledge that people with
schizophrenia are much more likely to
smoke than the rest of the population
and it's always been assumed as this
this is because we're all set to
problems they have a miserable life hear
voices in people and against them well
psychiatrists and nurses intended to see
well Brussels is one of the few
pleasures cigarette smoking let them
smoke but we've now been a realized that
the people who smoke do much worse
people who if you go to chronic
a unit for chronic people with chronic
psychosis ill everybody smokes and a
book that Excel could be that that could
be a consequence of the illness so we've
looked at people with their first
episode of cycling people their first
step
psychosis are three times more likely to
be smokers than people who are not
psychotic so why are they smoking
because they weren't psychotic so there
is something something that is driving
their smoking before they before they
develop a psychosis and there are no for
prospective studies which show that
adolescents who smoke cigarettes smoke
taking nicotine are more likely to
develop a psychosis so I think that they
say cigarette smoking does indeed
increase the risk of fake psychosis
thank you our next question an attendee
is wondering if there are treatments
specific for psychosis caused by
environmental and social factors in
young adults
well no but this has not been properly
explored until now most therapy has
assumed people with schizophrenia are
always seen and get a combination of an
anti-psychotic and dopamine blocker and
we get cognitive behavior therapy that
would be the standard therapy in Europe
so you get psychological treatment and
you get an anti-psychotic but what they
it is quite right doesn't there's
somebody who's had child abuse and whose
life has been troubled by that since
they sense their youth then they
obviously need a lot more psychological
therapy than somebody who developed a
psychosis following the abuse of
methamphetamine so I think we're just at
the beginning like this but I think
there are some people for whom
psychological treatments are going to be
much more helpful and once they are more
developed and I think there will be
particular treatments which may be
useful for people who've developed for
psychosis following the abuse of
cannabis for example one of the other
constituents of traditional cannabis is
kind of a dial which say good minish is
the effect of THC and there's
evidence that a cannabidiol blocks the
effects of THC and we are experimenting
with its use and people cannabis related
psychosis so I think in the future and
will indeed be specific therapies for
different types of people with
schizophrenia thank you
our next question does the dopamine
blocker cause the patient to get very
sleepy or zombie-like yes one of the big
problems in treating people with
schizophrenia is that if you give a
dopamine blocker then it not only a
tends to diminish hallucinations and
delusions but it also blocks the drive I
mean what why do we need the vocal be we
need to commit for motivation at
enjoyment and if you block dopamine too
much then you end up just as you say
with somebody who is a bit wrong be like
now sometimes psychiatrist let's take
that and we think that zombie-like
behavior is what they call negative
symptoms and then they did that our
negative symptoms lack of motivation in
people with schizophrenia but one of the
commonest causes of what you're
describing is too much antipsychotic now
fortunately we don't give us big goodies
of antipsychotics as we used to and also
there are no different country
psychotics which have less a sedation
effect so something like old-fashioned
haloperidol would especially make
something zombie like some of the all
the older pain intramuscular injections
would do that but no some antipsychotics
which are actually partly activating so
a drug like Qatar proposal as much less
likely to cause this zombie like you
thank thank you our next question is
there a positive correlation between HIV
and schizophrenia No
I mean HND hiv/aids I there's no
relationship between as far as I know
between HIV and a an schizophrenia the I
suppose the only possible well I've
never seen any evidence for that the
only possible thing you might see is
that sometimes people with schizophrenia
are treated so badly and neglected so
badly that they end up on the streets
and they might do things we wouldn't
otherwise do I for money and food so bad
saying in general there's no association
between HIV and and convenien most of
the social and problems that people with
schizophrenia get into are because
they're poor impoverished and they have
to put up with such terrible
circumstances and if you think about it
people with schizophrenia are acutely
sensitized sensitive to the environment
they're much more sensitive than most of
us and yet most of us couldn't cope with
the circumstances that many of the
people with schizophrenia they have to
put up with in UK we don't have so many
homeless as an industry in this states
fortunately but our people with each
vineya we often go to a hospital for the
my Shearer room saying for somebody else
they really don't know they get
relatively little money they have
relatively they're in a bad part of town
we don't get any opportunities for
education they have a social life that
the rest of us will find toxic and of
course it is boxing to them as well and
they tend to break down again in a
sensible world I have the best a of
resources and be protected from all
these and respite ease but that of
course is not not the way we tend to
click any the unfortunate in Western
societies thank you our next question
what is your opinion on potential PMS
treatment
Renea so the question is PMS pls oh ma I
sew transcranial magnetic stimulation
well there are some interesting studies
looking at the question of
hallucinations and some have been
positive and saying that a
hallucinations are diminished or even or
even go away following in certain types
of TMS I think it's early days yet but I
think it's saying it it certainly was it
persevering I think we're at an
interesting point where there's not been
much advance in drug therapies recently
so we've been people are looking at
different types of treatment and I think
a cognitive behavioral therapy is now
established as being a useful adjunctive
treatment but there are also other types
of a psychological treatment and social
treatments which are useful the thing
the best thing for people with
schizophrenia is to normalize them so
that they live in a normal environment
the worst thing is for people to be
isolated staring at the wall and
hallucinating the longer that you spend
preoccupied with hallucinations and
delusions the more difficult it is to to
get ready to get rid of them and that's
understandable for most of us our
memories are full of they are families
or holidays or work if you've been
hallucinating for the last six months
your memories are full of hallucinations
and paranoia and the longer that goes on
more difficult is to get rid of that so
even if somebody who's with someone
family can stay in the same medication
but if they can go and work in a
voluntary shop they can meet other
people the best thing for anybody would
say well say
schizophrenia was to get a partner and
to
begin to have you know to have the same
kind of life as the rest of the
population this I think is much more
beneficial than anything the
psychiatrist can do thank you our next
question what is a risk factor with
urban if cities the major factor is
supposed to be social stress and not
pollution or bad food well people have
looked at pollution and they haven't
found much people look for example that
laid at the laden petrol and led in the
atmosphere and there wasn't safe fun to
be any any relation by the best studies
of course are from Scandinavia where
they can I really look at the whole
population and they can look at risk in
different areas I and generally speaking
they find that the risk is greatest in
the areas of most social a social
fragmentation so if you live in a poor
area where you don't know your neighbor
and a you don't identify with the people
around you they don't have any proper
social relations with them then this
seems to push up above the risk in my
area in South London the process of
parts of south London bread that is the
highest incidence of schizophrenia other
areas where fewest people vote in a
general election
it's not just poverty it's whether you
feel you're part of the community enough
to go out and vote in a general election
because you think you can change things
it's the areas where nobody thinks they
can do anything and they can influence
things you walk down the street you
don't know because it's full of
strangers and some of them might say Rob
you are they are assaulting that sort of
area that seems to make people more
paranoid and more prone to develop a
schizophrenia so we don't know well let
me give another example I said in
Britain and in Europe people black
people have an increased risk of
psychosis not misdiagnosis we know that
this is the symptoms
of schizophrenia but if you live in an
area a with lots of people of the same
ethnicity live for example near our
Hospital there's an area where people
from the Caribbean lives and it's very
lively interesting area and you go to
the the markets include Caribbean food
and reggae Bob Marley is building out
over there over the sound systems and so
on people don't have a very high rate of
psychosis there but like people who are
living in a predominantly white area
where they don't feel they have any
social support and we feel that the
white population is hostile to them they
have a higher incidence of psychosis
there so it does seem that social
support and a interactions with others
are very beneficial why why are most of
us not psychotic because our social
interaction has been normalize us you
know if any of if any of us came into
work tomorrow and somebody said a what
happened to you yesterday you say oh
well was very curious I was kidnapped by
little green men who took me off to our
planets and assaulted me we would get
him fed back that that was a bad idea so
we wouldn't repeat it again might
actually I begin to doubt that it
actually happened to us but if you're
socially isolated you can develop these
bizarre and delusional ideas without
them being corrected rather than by a
normal social interaction thank you we
have time for one more question when
seeing one's child experiencing serious
acute stress in Bulleid social stress at
school how can we help the child to not
feel the stress too much and lower the
risk of developing schizophrenia well I
wouldn't like to exaggerate and say that
you know that bullying is that you know
it's a very small proportion of children
who are bullied whatever going to
develop schizophrenia I think one
probably has to have the vulnerability
now bullying is not good and and
children to a bully they're going to
have say
lots of other problems but I don't think
one should immediately worry about
somebody who's bullied developing
schizophrenia unless there is a family
history of the disease I don't have any
a magic a inform formula for that I
think one has to increase the
self-confidence or off of your child and
one has to take it up with the teacher
and one has to try and encourage say
your child to be able to develop the
relationships and to become more popular
that's with in would to invite some of
the other children in the class maybe to
go out to go to the movies and go out
for the day try and support them and
developed and developing friends but I
wouldn't say have at the back of one's
mind that say just because one reacts
badly to bullying and this is
necessarily going to the same inkwon
developed schizophrenia these things
like bullying and child abuse I think a
most people who are subjected to these
recover it's it's the combination of we
are having the biological vulnerability
and the social adversity I think that
pushes people over the threshold into
psychosis and sadly if you don't respond
quickly didn't is Virginia thank you
unfortunately we are out of time today I
want to thank the audience for their
interesting questions and participation
in today's event and our speaker for
Robin Murray today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
the next few months you'll receive an
email from labyrinth alerting you when
this webcast will be available for
replay and we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event see you
next time goodbye